[Music]
jonathan is with us in san diego hi
jonathan welcome to the ramsey show
thank you how are you doing good man
what's up
yeah so um
uh i have uh about
45 000
debt um now i'm not particularly
concerned with it as of right now
um i that that does occur uh from
student loans um as i went to college
and got a
master's degree in chemical engineering
um but i've been having significant
trouble finding work
um
uh not because
you know i don't interview well or
anything like that in fact i've had
about half a dozen offers
um
over the last year that ended up getting
rescinded
because every time the company
gives me an offer and then they go
through a background check they find
some charges in my background report
that uh
basically you know you know they they
end up sending the offer as a result
so you got criminal charges
uh yes sir okay for what
um there are charges that stem from uh
a domestic violence incident uh they're
they're all misdemeanor charges going to
the um
uh in the sense they're like two and a
half years ago after finding out that my
ex-girlfriend or girlfriend at the time
was unfaithful
okay
all right and how long ago was that
uh about two and a half years
my probation ends actually uh in
december in a few months
okay
well i want to encourage on something
this is this is not surprising but i'm
actually sharing an article this week on
the ken coleman show about how more and
more companies especially right now
uh with the lack of uh employees
available with 10.4 million jobs uh
available and 8.3 million people
unemployed
uh they are open to hiring people with a
criminal background now i i'm going to
tell you that it's it's not necessarily
going to be easy but this is uh becoming
more and more of a thing and i think
that number one you're going to have to
take
this
by the horns this bull by the horns is
so no longer when you go forward are you
waiting for a company to do the research
and find out about it this is where
they're killing you yeah you've got to
tell them on the up front uh when the
interviews get good and uh i would you
know they're calling you back and you're
starting to make some headway i would
explain it i would also go another step
further if you have yet to get some
counseling
i would do that and i would have a good
counselor
really you know pour into you and also
vouch for you that that not only have
you paid your uh you know that your
crime your time on these misdemeanor
charges but that you're going the extra
step to dealing with the anger issues
that came from some obvious pain i think
if you own this
i think you can overcome this in fact no
i don't think i know you can uh and i'm
going to give you one other piece very
practical advice as you're going for
these jobs in the future and you may
have already done this but make
absolutely sure that you are having
people that know you well and can vouch
for you that are that are taking you to
these companies to say hey this is a
really great guy this is a really great
candidate and he's overcome some
challenges in the past but i can vouch
for the character and the quality of
this human being i think if you put all
that together and you own this on the
upfront you got a much better chance
yeah the that's exactly right and that's
what's killing you here you've got to
come out
early in the process as soon as they
start nibbling on the hook you got to
tell them what's going on and just all
you have to do jonathan is just think
about what if you were hiring under what
circumstances would you hire a guy that
had that record
if you thought he was past it if you
thought it was a one-time thing if you
thought it's never going to happen again
he's been seeing a counselor it's in his
past everybody is screwed up one time or
another in their life
and but but if they don't think that
you're past it and they think oh i'm
gonna have a guy in a me too world
that's gonna hit a girl
nobody wants that on their payroll you
wouldn't want it on your payroll right
yeah
so you gotta you gotta weave the
a truthful
story a truthful narrative here that
says okay now here's what you're gonna
find you're going to find the 18 months
ago and here's what happened and here's
what i've done since then and uh i'm
perfectly clean the probation's almost
complete been seeing a coach and a
counselor here's what she says here's a
letter from them and this is what you're
going to find if this makes it a no if
any the fact that those charges are back
there are going to kill the deal we
might as well kill it now because i want
you to know now
and if you tell us that at ramsey
we you know
i'm a lot more concerned with what
you're going to do in the future than i
am what happened to you in the past
because i hadn't met anybody that has an
unblemished past
uh the only thing i'm worried about is
are you going to be defined by that and
is this going to be a continued pattern
and then i've got to deal with it as
your employer because you're going to
embarrass us by being in the news the
next time that comes along and i don't
want you on the payroll
uh and plus i don't want to end i don't
i don't want to employ someone that's
going to be doing that kind of stuff and
you don't either jonathan do you
correct yeah um i i i actually wanted to
say uh as um
uh
the the thing the reason
mainly why i'm calling now you know not
after the first time this happened is uh
this most recent uh
offer uh that was rescinded
i was at a company where i actually had
um
two people there vouching for me and uh
um
i you know it's it's something kind of
surging that uh yeah well that's
depressing and that's a gut punch yeah
did they tell them though and when they
vouch for you did they also tell them
that you had some misdemeanors in your
background
uh yeah they did yeah well i'm going to
tell you something you did all you could
do you did all you could do but you
don't quit
somebody's going to give you you are not
defined by the worst thing that you ever
did yeah
none of us are
hey man i file bankruptcy now i give all
of america financial advice go figure
that one out
i mean really
how absurd
but the difference is is that i learned
from it i've never been there again
and it makes me trustworthy and the fact
that i felt the pain of real life makes
me trustworthy
because i can relate to people who are
hurting which is like everybody
and or everybody has it one time or
another because most everybody's done
something stupid right so
you know you got one of your stupid
things out while you were young
it's in your past
um
you know
most of us that are old have often
commented that if twitter and um
instagram had been around when we were
in college none of us would be
employable
because there would be photographic
digital uh evidence of our behaviors
so um yeah
can you imagine when streaking was
popular
in the 70s
just the stuff we did to our friends
that we thought was funny would be
considered criminal level bullying and
we were just being idiots and making
each other laugh i mean goodness great
probably a lot of everything but yeah
not not making light of or minimizing
what you got convicted of that's not a
good thing yeah and we're not endorsing
that uh but we are trying to
give some grace
so that you can give yourself some grace
because you've already run into a lot of
places that aren't going to give you
grace yeah and so grace is i'm not
defined by my past
yeah i'm not defined by my past i get to
make new decisions starting today ready
set go i get to be a new kind of man a
new kind of woman starting today
ready set go and so if that's you dude
uh you got our endorsement and i think
you'll get a job but don't wait till
they get far down into the interview
process because then they feel tricked
they feel like you're trying to slide
one in on them and that doubles down
then because you got deception and a
criminal record is the way it feels from
the employer's viewpoint that's how i
would feel if i were if ramsay were
interviewing you and then we get this
guy's really talented but we got way
down into it before he brought this up
uh and one other encouragement i don't
know what your work situation is now we
didn't get into it but i would stay
active even though you're going for this
over here if it's got to work two three
jobs don't let yourself fall into this
idle matter anymore and i'm a stain that
would be really discouraging absolutely
staying with it do something until it
pops keep moving keep moving keep your
feet moving keep your feet moving you're
gonna be all right brother